paying for dogs that are trained to find
bombs yeah find them taking them through
high schools to find dime bags yeah
Chadwicks blunt yeah exactly
you know whoever's blunt so I should
always freaks me out at the airport the
bomb dogs yeah like what what if someone
like just dropped drugs in my bag or
something yeah yeah like what happens if
I'm like someone comes over mm-hmm and
they're like doing coke or something you
like drop some of my bag it's lying on
the floor or so just like some weird
[ __ ] like that really just what happens
if there's just random drugs in my bag
no because I've brought no I mean flags
I've been around some rock stars okay
exactly
I mean literal rock stars I mean like
the product I've been hyper a few times
that's what I'm saying what if what
happens if I walk by and you're hyper
sanded and yeah I'm super hyper and the
dogs detect it cuz they always pick up
on that sort of stuff they can smell
hyper yeah and so often they get hyper
the dogs they start jumping up on you
and you're like I'm relaxed I'm relaxed
no I'm not I mean just jump around like
this then it's hard cuts during the
fortnight days hard cuts that [ __ ]
special gate that FBI meeting ladies and
gentlemen we got him like oh no cuff you
put you on the ground
we got him he's doing the [ __ ] he's
flossing he's flossing he's too hyper no
I'm not no I'm not no no no no no no I'm
not with dude a LeFort night we left
fortnight we left for tonight you know
we got to do we got to do a short sketch
it's like the show cops yeah and it's
just about like it's like to conflict
yeah so we got it we got reports of a
kid just way too [ __ ] hyper yeah he's
in this house up here so we're gonna
we're gonna check on things to see how
it goes Lee yeah we gotta call his
parents say he's being super random so
I'm just gonna go check it out I go
check it out
oh my god thank god you're here he's
upstairs he hasn't he has stopped
playing fortnight since 6 a.m. 7 o'clock
he has even done his homework yet that's
it I know it's Saturday but it's just
Sam relax ok oh my god oh my god we're
in your easy good hands trust us so we
relax we will take care of this I'm free
we will take care of but it's ok it's ok
I just found out my boyfriend has
schizophrenia so I'm afraid I have it
and I just this is just like this just
man can hit please relax ok ok ok so
just like as your concert John wake on
me John wake on me John wake on me
oh damn John wake on me you're here I'm
in there don't wake up ha got him just
down this is going down John wet oh that
is so random got him come on whit got
him got him you can't get me come get me
come where you are I first dance going
backwards through a cornfield doing the
[ __ ] Fortnight dance we're just
chasing him the cameraman's going
running after this is a classic stand a
better forget the Dead's Ned I'm a
really good making fun of the [ __ ]
cameraman on cops oh yeah how he's more
fit than the actual cop that's great
like criminals always running like
looking back he like looks back Hamid is
passing no you're like look back and
then he's like sees a fence he jumps
over a fence is that the camera guy just
like there's a grip behind him just like
letting out slack on the broadcast
cables just like hard like cinema guys
from [ __ ] like Clint Eastwood's crew
just it's fine it's fine I got it I got
it I got it I got it
take that clip out of context
come on come on come on more rope more
rope more rope
yeah can we fly in some more flying some
more a coax copy copy do the monitor is
running right behind him - just watching
the screen and now watch where he's
going
and the director is just parallel to it
and then like whenever the camera jumps
they time to jump just a hole that would
be funny as [ __ ] oh my god just a whole
crew chasing this dude through a
cornfield cops were way that we always
booked them on evidence so they they get
them yeah usually on evidence and then
yeah okay well no the criminal runs out
of breath yeah and the camera guys catch
out to him and just quiet alright we got
the shot cutting cutting that was great
that was great that was great
nice work nice work yeah appreciate it
good luck oh we got some good stuff
there that was great dude in Reverse
yeah guys picking up the cable
[Music]